if you're not sure what business to
start go get some experience try working
for a company that you admire and see if
that's the industry you want to work in
and learn the ropes
otherwise you're going to spend your
time your money your effort
going down the wrong path and likely
ending in failure
hi i'm evan carmichael i believe that
hunger entrepreneurs deserve help today
i'm answering a question from a youtube
viewer
tj jesus 33295
great name all right so he wrote in
saying i'm about to enter college and
major in business
i want to learn more about it not sure
what to do after but i'm sure it could
excel in business just not sure how in
addition i'm a very creative person like
to know what kind of business job fits
me
and i could do well in please help me
and thanks for taking personal time to
read this
thank you so much again tj jesus 33295
listen if you want to start a business
number one rule the only rule that
really really matters is you have to
build it around your passion you've got
to do something that you love if you're
a creative person that's awesome
what can you do with that creativity
what do you love to do there's a lot of
ways to use your creativity are you an
artist are you a singer are you a dancer
are you
somebody who excels at computers what do
you
what are you creative with then figuring
out how to turn that into a business and
the best way to do it is look at
somebody who's already successful
look at somebody who's already done what
you want to do so if you're a graphic
designer say you love working with the
computers and you can great you know
create great graphic designs and you
want to have your own graphic design
shop that's a creativity thing you love
to do go find a company that's already
done it not a huge shop but somebody
with maybe 10 employees and go work for
them if you're in university now it
could be an internship it could be a
summer job you don't need to go work for
them for 10 years but go get some
experience it'll teach you a couple
things
first it'll tell you do you want to be
in this industry or not
a lot of businesses look great from the
outside people think oh that guy is
killing it i want to i want some of that
i want to be in that business
then when they actually started they
realized it's a lot harder than they
thought it was going to be the
rose-colored glasses come off and they
they're sorry they got into it
so know what you're getting into
by internship by having an internship or
by working at one of these companies
you'll see what it's like
and you'll see if you want to do this as
a business or not
you'll also learn
and this is so important you'll learn
what it takes to be a successful
entrepreneur from these guys
they'll show you
you just have to observe what they're
doing try to get as close to the
entrepreneur as possible a small shop
like that the entrepreneur i guarantee
you is in way over their head they're
doing way too much themselves and if a
hungry entrepreneur or employee comes up
to them and say i want more work
can i help out with something more than
what i'm doing they're gonna say yes
you're helping them out and you're
learning about the industry you're going
to make the mistakes on their dollar
you're basically getting paid to learn
about the business
you have to go hire a consultant to help
you
you're getting paid to learn how to be a
successful entrepreneur
you're going to make contacts you're
gonna have experience you're gonna have
connections
that when you decide to go launch your
business you have a much greater chance
of achieving success
so step one again find your passion
see what your creativity can do and how
you can apply it to business and then
step two go find a company that's
already doing ideally what you want to
do
and offer to work for them internship
summer job full-time job whatever it is
you'll take whatever evening work you
just want to get some experience you're
going to figure out if this is for you
or not
and if it is you're going to get paid to
learn everything you need to know about
the business before you launch your own
good luck hey i want to hear about your
success write back to me let me know how
you're doing and i'd love to do a
follow-up video as well for those of you
watching please give it a thumbs up
below i love seeing those thumbs ups
come in i know uh it means a lot to me
so i hope you'll do it and i also want
to hear from you please leave a comment
below about this video or about your own
business with a question that you have
i'd love to try to answer for you i wake
up every morning i eat my breakfast and
i watch the comments come in so i really
appreciate it i do read everyone that
comes in so thank you and i'll see you
on the next episode